you may remember the president of the
Harlem Children's Zone charter school
from the 2010 documentary Waiting for
Superman if not take a look at Jeff
Canada even the kids are getting
stupider every year or something is
wrong in the education system that
documentary analyzed the failures of the
American public education system some of
those failures will be major issues in
the 2016 campaign most Republican
candidates have been speaking out
against the common core education
standards and in favor of more charter
schools so let's take a look at some of
these issues with the one and only
Geoffrey Canada welcome thank you
you left the Harlem Children's Zone a
year ago yep so you sort of have time to
know take a step back where do you think
we are in terms of the American public
school system today this is really
troubling I have seen this sense that
common core is now bad setting standards
that everybody has to now say these are
the minimum standards people are backing
away from this and my Republican friends
are backing away from this I have enough
problems with my Democratic friends with
the unions are trying to determine and
run education so I'm getting it on both
sides and again no one's gonna like me
because it's a disaster for America how
on earth did educational reformers
snatch defeat out of the jaws of victory
it is something that I will tell you for
me and I have really been on this issue
as you all know for quite some time this
is something that we can't let up on I
have said to people there's this longing
for the good old days right let's go
back to the days where everybody could
set their own standards we could make
every could pass even if they can't read
and write
yes these are the teachers unions and
the folks who are trying to get away
from national standards with setting
benchmarks that determine what it really
means to have a quality education in
this country and I think that we've got
to take all of this stuff on one and I'm
telling you we got a uphill battle is it
just the teachers though Jeff what about
the parents clearly parents play an
important role in public education and
there
are well we see them right quoted in
these bleeding-heart stories my son
couldn't pass the tests he spent this
many hours it's not that I'm not
sympathetic to the troubles the families
have clearly but if the country doesn't
set a high standard or if municipalities
or states don't set a high standard and
follow through these poor kids are gonna
get left behind or then not not to
borrow a phrase from 2001 but they will
will they not while they are but let me
tell you this is a little bit more
insidious than this and for this reason
and this is what I said to President
Obama and Secretary Duncan common core
is not going to be turned back by poor
parents in Harlem and in Brooklyn it's
going to be parents and Long Island
parents in Westchester who don't want to
admit their schools are also struggling
and having trouble and so part of this
debate has been focused on just this
tiny slice of the American population
and it's a much bigger the bait why
wouldn't people want to admit that don't
they want their children to have the
best education possible so they can go
on to lead successful lives why lie to
yourself we haven't been honest with our
parents and the unions have the ability
to communicate with parents every single
day and they're telling them this stuff
is bad your kid is stressed out these
tests don't matter they don't mean
anything and parents are sitting there
saying well let me get this straight
you're telling me if I don't take the
test my kid is actually going to do
better and they're saying yes and we're
not pushing back outside of Governor
Cuomo we have not seen people push back
against something that's blatantly false
our unions stronger today than ever I
think they had they feel like they've
got some wins and this is this is a real
challenge because there's another thing
that's going on is they've masterfully
crafted a new dialogue which is rich
hedge fund folks are out to privatize
education and they're the ones yelling
for education reform and real people who
are sympathetic to poor folks don't care
that's how they stole the narrative back
because in that movie the clip of which
we played at the outset you know the
teachers unions were effectively public
enemy number one they came up with a
brilliant counter which is that we were
anti-teacher and they have sold this
over and over again those people don't
like teachers that's why they're saying
we should get rid of lousy teachers and
you know what we were not organized
enough to counter that narrative and now
that's part of the narrative that has to
do it Waiting for Superman and it also
has to do with education reform in
general but is education reform this
movement isn't losing steam is it going
to get the attention it needs in the
presidential campaign well if I have
some of these folks are my friends on
both sides of the aisle right so chris
Christie I consider him a friend and I
am going to be out in Salt Lake City
talking with Republicans about this and
I'm gonna bring this thing I'm asking
you do they want you there are you know
no they don't why people don't want to
hear the bad news this is bad news this
bad news says it's not just these poor
kids in Harlem it's your kids also that
are in trouble and folks are saying you
know what I don't want to hear that I
want to go back to this belief that
everything's gonna be fine
and I think that is really dangerous or
in this country and to that extent we've
been outmaneuvered right and I think but
it doesn't mean to me that this is going
to continue we're going to fight back
there a group of us saying right now we
can't lose this battle the country is at
stake
Jeff Canada is being